hey youtubers is Charlie my Game of
Thrones season 4 countdown continues I
think we've done three or four videos by
now during the breakdown of that last
trailer I asked you to submit all of
your questions so I picked 10 of them to
answer in this video with one bonus
question
most everybody wants to talk about the
Titan here if you're finding me for the
first time I'm just doing a special Game
of Thrones countdown series to the
season 4 premiere I've got a whole bunch
of cool stuff planned be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'm even doing a special giveaway
whenever the season starts now it's time
to talk about some Braavos careful for
spoilers if you're not caught up on the
show yet but here we go question number
one comes from Nino de Toro do you think
will seek a to the canals house of black
and white this season based on the Titan
being in the trailer based on the Titan
yes I think we will see Braavos but not
in the way you think there's a lot of
different stories tied up in that
location during various parts of the
story but the one I think we'll see is
sir Davos at the iron bank
remember Mark Gatiss is playing taiko in
the stores someone who works at the iron
bank
Stannis had no money during season two
whenever he borrowed all those ships
from Salladhor saan the funny thing
about that scene was that all that sands
seemed to want was to have sex with
Cersei whenever they took King's Landing
but since that very expensive fleet was
torched with wildfire
Stannis has no more ships and no money
so Davos is getting sent to borrow more
you know
enter Mark Gatiss question number 2
Penryn organs to nests when the show
catches up with the books will they do a
prequel series like for duck and egg or
Robert's rebellion yes there will be a
prequel TV series at some point but
it'll take place way back in the past so
that means no Dunkin egg and no Robert's
rebellion george RR martin was signed to
an HBO development deal of his own
around season 1 or 2 I personally want
to see the series set in old Valyria
before the doom I think that'd be really
cool it's the same situation with Robert
Kirkman at AMC though they also signed
him to a development deal for a Walking
Dead spin-off show it's just because
those worlds are so popular and HBO and
AMC want to keep that type of content
going for as long as possible
no announcements have been made about
the Game of Thrones prequel series but
it's a David Benioff and DB Weiss three
years to make the first pilot for the
current Game of Thrones show Plus
Martin still has to finish winds of
winter then he has to write dream of
spring so he is a busy man question
number three tailor Simpson asks will
they add scenes for characters that
aren't in feast for crows or dance with
dragons so you're talking about the same
thing they did with Theon last season
where they included him even though he
wasn't in the books corresponding to
what they were doing they're gonna
rearrange things so that they happen
chronologically it just makes it easier
to follow a story when you don't jump
back and forth and time too much junior
Tolkien had the same problem with his
books so Peter Jackson had to rearrange
the chapters for the movies just so the
events unfolded one right after the
other as far as extra things they're
really just blending feast for crows and
dance with dragons they will cover all
of those books but most of the
characters that aren't in feast are in
dance so logically it just makes sense
to do events from the beginning of both
books a lot of the chapters from the
second half's of those books though will
spill over into season five probably
question number four formal gab boom
asks is anyone going to go to Braavos
since we saw the Titan so yes Davos like
I mentioned I think he's actually going
to go there this season but I do think
that we're gonna get teasers for some of
the other characters that'll eventually
end up there really there are like two
to four characters that eventually end
up there depending on how you look at it
question number five
Sergio Valdiserri asks do you think Ned
Stark will come back and what do you
think the cliffhanger will be this
season so the only way Ned Stark would
come back would be as a white you know
reanimated corpse even then since he's
lost his head I don't think that the
White Walkers would be able to reanimate
him the only way to kill them is to burn
their bodies so I guess they could
reanimate his head so that he's just a
biter like the ones in the governor's
fish tank on Walking Dead as far as
cliffhangers there are several events in
the middle of books four and five that
would be good all of the characters
really have multiple oh moments so
no matter where they choose to end it
it'll be awesome question number six
Stephen Hugh asks will we finally get to
see Barristan Selmy fight this season I
hope so
the show stays really close to the major
plot points but it does take a few small
liberties with the characters every once
in a while as we've seen in the trailers
Daenerys still has a major battle of
head of earth and while Selmy scenes
make him seem like more of a
talker and less of a stabber I think we
will see him get tough with some people
Dario is really the stabby one in her
camp the one who gets sent out to
quote-unquote to take care of things
sell me is really more of a counselor
like sir friendzone you know with way
less creepiness question number seven
Connor Peckham asks I kind of want to
start with the books but I want to start
reading where the show is right now
which book should I start with so
honestly if you wanted to start wherever
we are right now in the story you'd have
to start reading about halfway through
storm swords if you really want to be
quick about it though you can just read
spoilers for that stuff and start
reading feast for crows season four is
gonna be kind of weird in that it
combines chapters from the first halves
of books four and five so you will miss
out on some stuff no matter what but I
think that if you're gonna read the
books you should read them in the order
they were published not in the order
that the show is doing them whenever the
season does start I'll actually try and
reference chapters in the books whenever
the events happen on the show just so
people can compare if they want to
question number eight Lissa Cunningham
asks how far into Cersei storyline do
you think they'll get this season so I
think they're only gonna get about
halfway through her characters arc so
there's gonna be a lot of big stuff
spilling over into season five
with all the mega stuff going on at
King's Landing already including
everything from her chapters seems like
it would be way too much for the story
to handle the problem with adapting
everything in a single book for a single
season of the show is just that it would
get way too disorganized I mean they're
huge books and remember Cersei is not
gonna be in every single episode
question number nine where you can see a
asks who do you think is the most
important character or will become the
most important character so this is
actually a huge debate but george RR
martin has said in the past that he most
identifies with tyrion i always felt
that a lot of fantasy authors make some
of the narrative autobiographical in the
sense that the character that they
identify with the most becomes the most
important character that's not always
the case but there's something really
logical about the way David Benioff and
DB Weiss went about casting Peter
Dinklage
he's the highest-paid actor on the show
but if you're wondering they are staying
true to his characters arc as george RR
martin has kind of plotted it out the
other clear choice is Daenerys she's
been the face of the show on the posters
and the marketing
everything for the last couple of
seasons now I think the really awesome
thing about Game of Thrones is that
unlike say the Hobbit or Lord of the
Rings
there is no single main character but if
I really did have to pick it would be a
tie between Tyrion and Daenerys question
number 10 Henry Martin Fiat asks how do
you think that the first episode will
start so typically the first episode of
each new season of Game of Thrones
starts right after the events of the
previous season's finale so if you re
watched the last episode of season 3
will basically just start season 4 a few
days after that so Jon Snow
just came back to the Nights Watch
Daenerys just freed all those slaves
Jaime and Brienne just came back to
King's Landing you know all those places
will be where we'll start in episode 1
and one last bonus question Leon Tandon
asks how many seasons will that be so
the showrunners actually just did a
really cool interview in Vanity Fair
where they talked about how george RR
martin basically told them how the show
is gonna end they said they went to
George RR Martin's house in New Mexico
to learn how the rest of the story ends
for each character just because by the
time they get through season 5 they'll
have passed where he is in the books
they didn't reveal any spoilers of
course but they did say they have enough
content for seven solid seasons maybe an
eighth depending on whether or not HBO
would pay for it believe me they will
definitely pay for it so for now we can
say of confirmed seven but in reality I
think it'll be 8 so thank you so much
for submitting your questions this was a
lot of fun as always right now I'm
actually working on getting live
streaming running on my channel so I
might do live Q&A in the future I'm also
working on doing live after shows you
know after TV shows are done at least
the big ones you know like talking dead
works right after Walking Dead there a
lot of bugs I have to work out but it
should be pretty cool once it works
hopefully all that'll be ready to go by
the time Game of Thrones gets started
the episodes get started so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
and all the rest of my countdown videos
it's gonna be a lot of fun the next game
of Thrones video that I'm gonna be doing
tonight is actually going to be the
history of dragons video remember
because they started in Valyrian they
came to Westeros etc etc that'll
probably post really really late tonight
but in the meantime you can click here
to watch all my breakdown videos for
season four and
click here to watch my walking dead
predictions video that I just posted
there's only three more episodes to go
in the season thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you